it's a challenge requiring great skill
and determination it's very complicated
how to fix the country's social care
crisis the pm on a care home visit to
sell his new plan
he lost this battle but hoping for
better luck for his big manifesto
busting policy
the first step to win over his cabinet
some are deeply uncomfortable about
breaking the pledge not to raise
national insurance
but at the cabinet table sign off agreed
and publicly at least these cabinet
ministers hold in their tongues
facing the commons and admission i
accept that this breaks a manifesto
commitment which is not something
which is not something i do likely but a
global pandemic was in no one's
manifesto mr speaker
rather than an expected rebellion his
mp's supportive can i thank the prime
minister for biting the bullet on this
intractable issue that i and many former
health secretaries have wrestled with
can i congratulate the prime minister
for delivering on our commitments and
his commitment this day shows just how
much the conservative party has changed
under boris johnson a key manifesto
promise broken billions of tax rises
announced and millions of workers told
they'll have to pay more in national
insurance
contributions the pm is radically
redrawing what the conservative party
stands for and admits all of that barely
a whisper of public criticism from
conservative mps for decades the party
of low taxes the pm wants it to be the
party of the nhs
lead in the public sales pitch an
emotional appeal from the pm we will do
what is right
and reasonable and fair we will remove
the anxiety of millions of families up
and down the land
by taking forward reforms that have been
delayed for far too long when you were
making this decision was there not part
of you
that worried about it and thought that
at some point voters will lose
faith in you and you will lose
credibility not just for yourself but
for the conservative party as well
nobody in any
manifesto that i read uh saw a pandemic
coming i have to take a a judgment make
a choice about what i think is the
higher priority will you actually just
tell the public now that's it you're not
going to spring another tactic
your approach what i can certainly tell
you is that uh the the the stand before
i can't there are not uh many people in
the conservative party uh who are more
uh
dedicated to cutting
taxes bearing down on taxes where we can
than the three people standing before
you today
the prime minister now refusing to rule
out further tax rises aware his
manifesto promises painted him into a
corner he's broken his word without
breaking his party the question is will
the public swallow it too beth rigby sky
news westminster